the worse it looks from the more
handsome and brown and rich and he's a
spectacular villain and and I can't I
rather liked him and that's the ultimate
villainy ron was big enough and
confident enough to be able to say why
don't you spend a couple of days having
the cutting-room dashing in between but
on Friday he didn't keep all over it was
our flew out I did that you know it's a
rite of passage the screenwriter on his
way out to meet mr. Spielberg I was
sitting in the room which was the
boardroom you know and an incoming
assistants head mr. Spielberg will be in
shortly if I draw an another system came
in and turned all the lights off we had
a meeting in the dark but as you know
actually sorry you know as as one you
know as you got used to it it was kind
of really relaxing I mean we weren't
really you know we weren't naked or
anything and I got quite into it the
story comes first so in other words an
idea comes first and it's a controlling
idea that's a theme and then the scenes
that I choose because you know often
they spanned a period of six months or a
year where you could choose any number i
mean these are busy people you know and
they have that they've done a lot and
but i will pick the ones that support my
conjecture I'm still finding hugely
proud of the deal I I don't know if it's
my favorite but it's certainly it's got
better and whereas a lot of fun but
worse I think that one made me feel like
to do I think i started calling myself a
writer
you